Um, the main thing I want to do this
morning, so I've got an hour and a half
before this presentation. This
presentation will be streamed live here.
probably will stand up and move this
chair maybe. But um this will be live
and
I think I've got just enough time before
this to see if we can fix up the
uh the architectures
like the way we're handling networks in
the code.
It's really really freaking complicated
because there all these buffers floating
around.
Yeah, it's just getting very very over
complicated I'd say here.
So it's only for the master weight,
right?
Which like this is the expected design.
This is what it should be.
Yeah, I did something weird here, right?
This create policy.
Hey, Spencer. Yeah. Um, it's actually
it's really freaking tough to get a
clean way to do the policies here so
that we can have multiple encoders and
stuff cuz like everything's getting
registered to static buffers and we have
mixed precision. So, I'm trying to clean
this up. It's quite fancy. Oh yeah, I
forgot to reply. I saw your thing and
then I went to dinner. I got to watch
the clips, but otherwise I think we'll
be good. Um,
okay. Yeah, working on this is also
solid.
Uh, though do get some time off this
weekend as well. Please uh get some
rest. I can look at the clips with you.
Let's say after um we can even do later
this afternoon if we want to do like a
short session on some stuff just to make
sure sure stuff is on track. I have the
talk for uh Warwick at 11 Eastern, so in
an hour and a half. I'm going to try to
clean this up first and then see if I
can just get a little bit more done on
this.
It's tough because like you know now
that we're doing it this way, if it's if
this is not clean, it's worthless,
right? Like this has to be clean. Um, it
really really has to be like, okay, this
is clearly better than the torch version
tomorrow. Uh, I can do sometime
tomorrow. Yeah, that's good.
Spending a couple days working on MPS
support. Do you care for that? Not quite
ready for PR.
Um, so MPS support will definitely work
for the
the uh torch back end. How is Wait, you
can't just run CUDA on MPS though,
right?
because our native 40 background uh back
end is all CUDA what Warwick talk given
a talk for uh Warwick University uh to a
bunch of undergrads. It'll be streamed
here live as well.
I'll probably like shut the stream off
and then shut like turn it back on right
before as well so it like is easy to
clip it for YouTube. We'll see.
Okay. So I guess And the main thing is
right
right here uh neural mmo puffer lib
working on like really long form out
there projects for many years that
eventually become broadly useful like
it's just a lot of stuff about all the
work I've done and supposed to be kind
of a cool story for the undergrads also
introduce them to a really awesome area
of AI that sort of thing. Hey Liberty.
Hey Sully. How's it going?
it's this right
these suck
register. Yeah these all these helpers
all suck
Uh if you get it in the base case, we
can domain randomize. I'm pretty
confident.
Like the thing that we discussed in
particular, which I you already kind of
had a version of, but was a little
janky,
but I think I have a good like there's a
good sol for that if you basically make
it just like a box instead of a line.
But we'll talk about that soon.
Yeah. So this I don't like any I hate
having these lambda anon functions
everywhere. So then I guess the question
is
these are here because
yeah these are here because of mixed
precision right
uh rag rads
only gets used once
Yeah, I'm just I'm essentially I'm not
happy with the complexity overhead here
because if you think about what's going
on in training, we have uh several
static buffers for parallel rollouts
that have to store activations. We have
the weight and grad buffers. The weight
buffers have to be for BF-16 and for
FD32.
Um we have the
Was it the in uh we also have the train
buffers for the train rollouts.
Those also need grabs.
There's just a lot of stuff going on
here and it has to not be such a mess.
Yeah. See, it's inlined it here. This is
really bad.
And why does it do this?
Oh, it's
Yeah. What the heck?
The init weights also only gets called
once, dude.
Okay, maybe this isn't as bad as I
thought. This might just be this model
being stupid. So,
I think we can
Uh
well, hang on. The key insight here
though,
I No.
Uh
cuz the activations become BF16, right?
What's the presentation about?
Presentation will cover neural MMO. It's
like an a bridged version of stuff from
my thesis um for an undergrad audience
with more focus on like the journey and
that sort of thing. It's more casual as
well. Uh, it's also going to include a
little bit of the latest stuff on the
stuff from like RLC presentation
building puffer lip where that stuff
came from and then a little bit free
form at the end about some of the latest
stuff I've been working on plus a bunch
of Q&A
I probably I don't know if I live stream
the Q&A or not.
I'll probably I can live stream my
portion of the audio. I probably can't
stream the question. So, I'll just like
repeat the question.
Importantly, I'm not going to be taking
questions
um from the chat during the
presentation. I'll actually have it like
closed at the top or whatever most
likely. Um however,
uh
I will take questions after I finish
with Warwick and I jump off the call
with them. If people have questions and
want to save them, I will still be
streaming. So you'll be able to ask them
What does this even do? So, this calls
create policy.
And this calls encoder in
which does what? It registers
parameters.
Hello, Joseph. Are you in Poland?
What? No, I am not in Poland.
It's uh online.
Wait, is that where Borick is? Is it in
Poland?
England.
That's what I thought
with my son. He's Eugi studying mecha
engineering. Oh, very cool.
Yeah, it'll be live streamed and if you
miss it, it's also um it'll be on
YouTube.
any engineering student with um actually
even like a first programming course in
systems. It has to be a systems course,
but a first programming course in
systems uh can pretty much just jump in
and start doing RL if that's a fun
thing.
Hey, Anes
your intern this year? Yes, it's um
he's one of the organizers of that uh of
the presentation series. Yeah,
we have not discussed the start date
with Finn, but he can just start
whenever he wants in the spring. We said
it'll be like 12 weeks.
David Silver very famous. Yes.
Of course.
Yeah. You really can't let these models
design anything. They'll design
anything. You let them design, they'll
design poorly.
I actually do wonder um I wonder how
much of the models being really bad at
programming is them being trained on
really bad code. Like I wonder if the
model would be get would just get better
if you just deleted the really bad code
from um the training set. I mean you'd
probably just end up with not enough
training code for the data set, I guess,
but
Let's see if this gets better.
I think the most likely thing is
well
it's a little bit annoying because I
don't know how we're going to do the
weight registrations.
It's very very important that we make
the uh the policy simple to work with.
Are you No, I'm not using that thing,
dude.
Let's see if this looks better.
Well, this is the init syntax I like.
Okay, let's see what other complexity
comes out of this.
Do you need
Let's make sure this didn't break it in
the process.
What's your token usage? Stupidly high
right now. The hope is that it goes down
to nearly zero. Um, once we have this
refactored,
because after this, like once we have
this actually clean, there's essentially
no other dumb things I'm forced to use
in the workflow, right?
It's just the process of getting the
waffle torch code uh into this is
not good. How on earth did it break Yes.
Oh, okay. Yeah, we're not going to let
it do it that way.
Try Codeex.
I don't know. I guess
I think ultimately if Gemini ends up
being decent, I'd rather use that. If
I'm just thinking of like which of the
companies I'd rather give uh money to,
it's pretty sad that it ends up being
Google of all of
Getting closer to see
D. Deis is so honest about a GI and
stuff. Um, Demis is a genius and like
actually with the way things shook out,
I think he's the only one who I still
have like a ton of trust and respect
trusted and respect for.
Like it's funny because it's when it
started I actually kind of didn't like
there are a lot of ways about uh with
how Deep Mind does stuff that I don't
really agree with but like
the other AI companies have just botched
it so hard that uh now that it makes
Deep Mind stuff look very very good by
comparison. So basically the thing that
I always say with Deep Mind right is
they do too much math for the sake of
them just liking to do math. Um so no
matter how what the best approach is to
solve a problem they will kind of always
just approach it from the perspective of
let's do as much fancy math as possible
and uh in the sort of the peak eras of
RL open AI was solving at least as hard
if not harder problems will using much
simpler methods which is better you want
to use simpler methods and they simply
had better engineering um whereas deep
mind just would not do the engineering
and end up with fancier math to
compensate, which is not the thing you
want to do. You want to have good
engineering and simple methods. Um, now
of course then the thing is that OpenAI
and the others kind of just stop doing
the stuff entirely. So I'd rather have
the overly complicated methods on stuff
actually still getting done. Um, but
it's it's a bit unfortunate.
there was like a much healthier balance
of engineering and science um at OpenAI
and even at like even some of the stuff
with meta for a little bit was though
that's was a little questionable. It was
kind of just like a small thing.
I don't know.
Hey Gwen,
lost their good. They never had any,
man. If anybody was watching them, like
if you were there when they split off,
it was literally just the crazy people
from opening eye leaving.
Like it was nutcases from the start with
them.
I don't have any more details than are
like public.
I mean, it seems fine. It's like, you
know, a bunch of gung-ho like, uh, we're
going to like solve the thing with a
small team, which is good. Um,
I really don't like their tech staff.
God damn. TypeScript and Rust is just
like a Now text.
I mean, this is better. We're not quite
there yet,
but this is better.
switching to Python.
I mean, that's not the fix either.
I honestly think that the best thing is
if you have real engineers, it should be
mostly just CUDA
unless you're on TPUs in which then
yeah, you're forced to use um jacks and
crap, but that's just awful awful.
All day one stream today. Uh, I'd say
mostly I have the talk at 11, so in an
hour we're going to go do that talk. I
will have the stream on for that. I'm
probably gonna like toggle the stream on
and off just so that it cuts so I can
clip it nicely for YouTube
to
a datathon today.
Is that where you like analyze a bunch
of data or is that where you go on a
bunch of dates?
XLA backend for torch is improving. I
don't care.
It's the wrong level of abstract. Like
that whole thing is just such a mess. I
don't want to touch it.
Look, I I would love to have something
where you could have multiple backends
easily. Um but honestly,
like Nvidia is just the only one that's
actually written a decent backend. Like
CUDA is good. Nobody else has something
good.
So,
we're gonna write CUDA up.
XLA is not human writable as far as I'm
aware.
Ain't that good thing? Deep Mind is very
mathy. Uh, it's a good thing to have the
capability to do a bunch of math. It's
not a good thing to uh use that as a
substitute for engineering
hackathon for data. All right, fair
enough. Cool. Good luck.
That sounds much less exhausting than
the other one.
See, this is still down here. This is
bad, right?
Oh, okay. I see. It's just duping the
code.
Who had better model back then? Alpha
Go. In my mind, it's Dota and it's not
even close. Oh, wait. Alpha Go. Okay.
Um, that one's harder. I read that as
Alpha Star. Um,
that one is harder to say. Um, because
it's really hard to understand the
complexity and go. In my mind, it's
Dota. For me, it's Dota. It's like a way
easier problem to map onto
um problems we care about elsewhere.
It's multi- aent. It's cooperative.
There's team war. There's team play.
There's theory of mind. Though there is
that in go as well. Um
and solve without search.
So for me it's Dota.
Doing math just to do math is success.
Yeah. Like a good version of this for
instance is like mulu, right? You do
some math, you understand some
preconditioning, you come up with a good
optimizer. It's actually good. There's
not another way to do it that's like
simpler. Like that's a good example.
A bad example would be like look at
Alpha Star versus look at Dota.
Dota to me was a far more impressive
project than Alpha Star.
you watching DN Finals today? Is that
today?
And I've always wanted to play one of
those. And um
it's just like such a sweaty game mode.
I never have time to do it. Even like to
play the first couple days and swap out
a bunch. I'll probably watch the um I'll
probably watch like a couple of the
videos that creators make out of the
finals.
Oh yeah, quick update. Uh vault since
you're the RS guy.
95 strength on the pure.
I actually am pretty excited though.
actually well uh one of the things I was
thinking I might even want to get an
intern for this at some point. Um so
I've been using the models here for a
lot of this refactor of torque and the
models are really really stupid. Um, but
if you are a good engineer that knows
what good code looks like, you can use
them to very quickly uh just port a huge
blob of bad code over to something else
and to apply a bunch of refactor ops.
I'm thinking like how hard would it be
to port an entire private server to see
um because like in my mind the best
possible RLM you could have would be
like that entire MMO but fast.
going to PK. I've had this account for a
long time, man.
I just never really finished it. So, I
figured I would just chuck this on the
side monitor since they added the
gemstone crap.
And uh I don't know. I've had this for
like several years. It was just I never
finished it.
It's not that hard.
for logic and safe vault if you're
interested in doing that with puffer. I
mean that's a project we'd be very very
interested in and if you do it well like
could probably have that be paid as well
at least like an internship level type
thing. I don't know what your own
situation is. Has to actually be good
though like you know the code's going to
have to end up being something that's
like quite compact and concise and it's
going to have to hit the perf targets to
be useful. I was starting with just the
inferno. I think that would be an easy
thing to finish because if we can solve
that, like that would be enough of a
demo to go, okay, if we have the entire
thing, right, and we can just drop an
agent in any part of it and just like
start solving individual bosses,
individual tasks, and then start
training stuff together. That's kind of
the perfect end for RL.
What's your opinion about S and silver?
Learning through
learning through experience is RL.
So I don't know what you mean by that.
That's RL in a nutshell.
What is created? It's just a Runescape
thing.
I don't know. Like MMOs have been a
really really big source of inspiration
for a lot of my research. So yeah, of
course I played some.
30-year-old dad can intern. Gotcha.
Can't
do for a job. That'd be amazing. I
gotcha. Yeah. The tough thing at the
moment is we're not hiring um we can't
really be hiring full-time since Puffer
works off of contracts. So like all of
our revenue comes from uh building Sims
for clients. So I typically when I hire
people, I hire them for a specific
contract and it's just a 50/50 split on
whatever that job pays. Um and this is
where this is more like centralized
internal dev. So like for instance I got
Finn on for the summer because he built
the drone end and you know we can take
interns that's fine but extended
full-time is really tough because uh
then it creates an obligation to me to
basically ensure that we have enough
steady stream of contracts and then that
they're allocated uh reasonably as well.
But I do think that um
if we could get RS in this end, it would
be so freaking cool.
It'd actually be so good for research as
well.
Like I think that we could get it to the
point where if it's built correctly, we
could have it so that any individual
boss in the game just gets full solved
instantly. uh as a harder project, we
could get it to the point that you could
solve like an entire raid
and then actually the open world stuff
would end up being the hard part. Then
that would be the longer term challenge.
Buffer's great. Do it himself and this
is a fun use of time. Very nice. I also
promote stuff for people as well. I've
gotten a couple people um one guy a job
offer at one place and a couple other
people recommendations for things.
But um yeah, it's it's pretty awesome
stuff overall.
I don't know if you've looked at the I
put it on the escape branch. There's
like um the basic inferno code. It's
actually not terrible. It is
handwritten. Uh, it needs to be cleaned
up and it's like nowhere near done, but
I got the basic mechanics, the pathing
and stuff correct, I think.
How you doing?
How are you doing, lead
lead genen?
I have no idea what that means, but how
you doing, man? I'm doing all right.
Yes. This is the problem here, right?
With the train activations
see where I take that. doesn't look like
you have a ton of time. Yeah, cuz I got
to finish this update and we also have
three or four activives at the moment on
client work
finding clients.
How are you doing lead?
Um I mean we're doing fine, Quinn, at
the moment. Like we have enough clients
that unless we get um some like larger
contracts or some good stuff, we're not
really we don't really need a ton of
more things at the moment. at least
until I finish for.
I'm starting to get larger contracts as
well, which is cool.
Cuz look at the train activations.
So, you have to register the train
activation. separately
and then what you got to register
gradients
would have applied it so many projects
in my past career in hindsight
uh you didn't miss out man it didn't
work back Then
like honestly two years ago all this
stuff would have been impossible. It
just the speed wasn't there and like a
lot of the things that we've done if you
just go here if you just go try to do
any of the same stuff with FP3 or any of
the other libraries you'll see
immediately like RL just doesn't work.
custom ends with buffer. But some reason
during training the episode return
starts high then goes down. Max one
sparse reward settings
then goes down.
Max one sparse reward then goes down.
Uh I need more information than that.
It's
All right. Could be hypers. Could be
that your obs are messed up. Could be
that you're like not the end is not
actually communicating data correctly. I
got a checklist in my RL guide for
common bugs. Is it because training was
slow? Uh for I would say that was at
least half of it was training was too
slow.
Another like quarter of it was things
that are a result of training being too
slow like not having optimized
hyperparams.
And then the last quarter was actual
legitimate algorithmic optimizations and
improvements.
Man, I'm really just not happy with this
at all.
approximately 2 mill SPS. It's
reasonable speed.
Um,
it depends how sparse the rewards are as
well, right? I would assume it's not
that sparse because if you're starting
at one, it means that it's getting it
randomly at the start, right?
Have you played the environment
yourself?
That's always a good one. It's it this
is in my tips and tricks, right? Like if
you can see if you can play the
environment yourself and if you actually
get the reward correctly, see if the obs
line up, all of that stuff.
and it waits on
FP32 master.
I mean, my guide has a pretty good
checklist. If you should run through
that first and then like tell me what
you've tried. Give me some details about
the end. Maybe link code if you want me
to help fix it.
Have you tried like submitting actions
through the uh submitting grid
environment? Like make the level super
easy as a test? Most of the time it's
most of the time it's cuz you have
something dumb in the end. Like the RL
is usually pretty good these days.
It's to the point now that when things
are bugged, I suspect the end more than
I suspect the RL at least for anything
like small to medium complexity.
No, if you show me that you have a
gigantic sparse maze and you're
wondering why it's not working, I'm
going to like flip the table. But other
than that, it should be good.
What do we think of something like this?
Is this better?
It's a whole bunch of allocators.
Well, I can pretty easily clean that up,
though. Hang on.
you do the create functions
and then the init functions.
Why can't the grad functions go in
there?
Oh, wait. Hang on. They do, don't they?
Yeah. This is just the whole grad
buffer.
Reward curves like a U. Did you run a
basic sweep?
Like stuff like that should normally
work. It's possible you got jank hypers.
Usually it's the case you're doing
something dumb like you're forgetting to
clear terminals or you know you're
forgetting to zero out rewards or
something like that.
The checklist has like really like at
least 80% of the issues people run into.
you did run a sweep. So yeah, if you ran
a basic sweep and it's not like and
start looking for any bugs like
have you gone through that checklist
like seriously
Yeah. And then we have these buffers.
Well, it's so complicated, man.
I really really don't like the way this
is.
So you end up you actually do end up
needing a API.
We can probably make it not that bad,
but
it sucks.
I I think I can at least make this
version way cleaner than it was before,
so it won't be that
So, this ends up basically we end up
back at the design we had before. Um,
just like cleaned up a lot.
I guess that happens, right? Where it's
like, oh, you think it's the wrong
design because you have a dirty version
of it.
But the correct approach is simply to
have a clean version of the design,
not to have a different design.
I'm trying to think if I'm being stupid
by not making this a um
No, this it's not stupid not making this
a C++. They different buffers.
I'm here like, oh, it's like I'm
reinventing OOP. But no, I'm not because
the thing is like
they take different buffers.
Well, okay. This isn't just being weird.
It doesn't have to be this.
It should just be decoder like that's
bizarro. Okay.
Um
and then we do the registers.
Is it error?
Yeah. What the heck is this?
Don't you get way What are the usage
limits on that, man?
rate limit reached.
Yeah. No, we're not doing that, man.
We're not dealing with the rate limits.
But it's equivalent to 1k of tokens if
you're using it like spaced out over the
month. Right. Perfectly.
There's a reason they priced it that
way.
It's fine. It's basically going to end
up having cost like $2 to $3,000 to um
have like a refactored olive torch and
then thereafter it should be nowhere
near as bad. Like I don't use opus very
much at all or any like I don't use
models very much at all when I'm doing
client work on Simpsons and stuff. It's
like I use it when I'm dealing with
complete and utter [ __ ]
which I guess got gives you guys the
wrong impression here that the models
are good. Like the models are very
stupid, right?
I don't even know what it thinks it's
doing here. Yeah, exactly. What? There.
Way better.
The determinism is actually very very
nice to have for development. Like holy,
that's a big upgrade. I didn't
appreciate how good that was until just
now.
like you basically can say that the code
base did not change at all.
The determinism is super useful.
Um,
okay. So now we have encoder decoder.
They're just strct initialized.
They're struck with methods
which
let me do this. Stop onelining
everything. Absolute
There we go. So that's what they look
like.
That probably would have saved me some
money.
How bad is it going to be if we end up
shipping something like this? Obviously
cleaned up.
I think this is not terrible with the
signatures cleaned up.
And um
yeah, this will ultimately this will be
enough to have it like useful.
The signatures will be fine and then
it'll basically be for an encoder you
need like Actually,
it's right here, right? This is the
whole code. So, for an encoder, it would
be like this.
Let's say that the signatures are half
the length. So, we don't have any of
these lines going off screen. Same
content.
One screen of code for an encoder.
It's more code than torch.
Um, but this is something much more
sophisticated than what torch is doing.
And there's absolutely nothing hidden
from you.
I think that's pretty good.
Yeah, that's pretty good. So, okay,
that's now that's now to the point where
I can clean that up in an evening or
whatever, doing like super easy work.
Um,
The next thing that we will work on,
there's some stuff in here with the
launch functions for sure.
There's also stuff in the kernels
and there's stuff in the optimizer.
So, we basically we've got lots of
additional things we can do still.
hate to uh add 100 lines of code, but
we'll have to resolve it. Okay, so
here's the plan, guys. It is now 10:40.
Got to do the restroom. I got to walk
around a bit. I got to make myself a cup
of tea. And I'm going to be back in 20
minutes
for the uh the Warwick AI presentation.
So, I'm actually going to turn the
stream off so that when I start it
fresh, I'll start it with a new title
and everything cuz uh you can't change
titles on X without restarting the
stream and that's going to be the main
spot pops up. So, I'll be back in 20
with that presentation and then I will
be live streaming the rest of the day.
Um so, you can come back for that. And
also, if you are new around here and you
want to help to support my work for
absolutely free, just take a moment,
star the puffer on GitHub. It really,
really helps us out a lot. Can join
Discord, can join Fallon X as well if
you want to get involved. And that's
about it. I'll be back with